IT WILL BE HARD FOR DEMOCRATS TO
DISMISS THIS.
>> Sean: THANK YOU.
JOINING US THE WHITE HOUSE
SENIOR ADVISE FOR SENIOR
COMMUNICATIONS.
THIS WOULD  WILL BE
INVESTIGATED.
WE ARE WAITING ON THE FIRST
HOROWITZ REPORT AND THAT'S BEEN
DELAYED.
IT'S GOT TO BE FRUSTRATING.
AT THE WHITE HOUSE THAT THE
WHEELS OF JUSTICE GRIND THIS
SLOWLY.
>> WHAT THE PRESIDENT WANTS IS
TO MAKE SURE THAT THEY CAN LOOK
INTO THE FISA AND FIGURE OUT IF
THERE WERE ANY POLITICAL ABUSES.
THERE HAS ALWAYS BEEN CONCERN
THAT'S WHAT THE PRESIDENT IS
PUSHING FOR.
>> Sean: I THINK THERE WERE
ABUSES.
SHE PAID FOR IT HILLARY CLINTON,
THEY NEVER TOLD THE FISA COURT.
THAT'S DECEPTION.
THE FBI HAS AN OBLIGATION TO
VERVIE IT.
VERIFY IT AND FUSION GPS NEVER
DID AND THEY LEAK PHONEY
INFORMATION.
WHERE DOES THE PRESIDENT STAND
ON THE ISSUE OF THE MILTARY?
THAT'S HIS NUMBER 1
RESPONSIBILITY.
HE HAD AN INCREASE IN THE
DEFENSE BUDGET.
I CAN'T THINK OF A MORE
IMPORTANT ISSUE TO NATIONAL
SECURITY THAN DEALING THE WALL.
DRUGS COMING ACROSS.
HUMAN TRAFFICKING.
ENEMIES CAN CROSS OVER AT WILL.
WILL HE USE THE DEFENSE BUDGET
MONEY TO BUILD THAT WALL?
>> THE PRESIDENT IS EXPLORING A
VARIETY OF OPTIONS.
THE BUDGET MONEY WITH THE
1.6-BILLION DOLLARS AGREED UPON
IS DEFINITE.
A DOWN PAYMENT TO ENSURE THAT WE
HAVE BORDER WALL FENCING AND NEW
CONSTRUCTION.
THAT'S CRITICAL.
THERE WILL BE PLACES ALREADY
WHERE THEY ARE GOING TO BE
REPAIRING THIS WALL FROM A 12
FOOT WALL TO A 30 FOOT WALL
WHICH WILL MAKE IT DIFFICULT TO
HAVE ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS COME TO
OUR COUNTRY.
SECONDLY IS THE PART OF
TECHNOLOGY AND PERSONNEL.
YOU ARE TALKING ABOUT A 10%
INCREASE IN ICE FUNDING.
THAT'S VERY CRITICAL TO ENSURE
THAT OUR NATIONAL SECURITY IS
TAKEN CARE OF AND THAT OUR THE
WALL IS BEING BUILT.
THAT'S SOMETHING AND A PROMISE
THE PRESIDENT IS KEEPING.